all right the fight for fairness in
women's sports continues according to an
exclusive report from The Daily Mail the
captains of the Rono College women's
swim team were forced to convince a
biological male student not to compete
with them and here's what the team said
at a press conference earlier
today why would I even try to if I was
going to have to race against a
biological man it was hard to even
function because every moment I had was
being consumed with what I was supposed
to accept as a new
a normal that I never agreed to be a
part of for the first time I considered
quitting something I had loved doing my
whole life our government is not
protecting women the NCAA is not
protecting women they had a legal
obligation to protect Fair athletic
opportunities for our female athletes
but instead we were forced to practice
and race against a biological male who
removes Fair sport for all of us now
Rono College responded to our requests
for a statement confirming they had
planned a board meeting on the subject
before the student withdrew their
request now noting they voted to adopt
the ncaa's policy on the issue and
meanwhile in Maine listen to this story
outrage growing there after one high
school Runner who placed
172 172nd in the boys division came in
fourth place in the girls division after
coming out as transgender okay here with
reaction director of what is now the
Leadership Institute Riley gains is with
us Riley how are you
I'm be a
great the Prime Minister of Great
Britain actually said it's just simple
you know boys or boys girls or girls men
or men women or women and that's the end
of it why is it that complicated um
especially when it comes to sports why
is there this Obsession if you come in
172nd in the men or boys Division and
you come in fourth in the girls division
it proves the point doesn't it that the
biological differences are very real now
that doesn't mean men are better or
women are not better actually I think
women are better than men in a lot of
ways however it's an unfair advantage
that's the
issue absolutely it's proven by that by
the examples that we continue to see
this is not happening the other way why
don't we see women infiltrating into
men's sports and dominating I mean that
right there is all you need to know what
we saw in Maine with this this male
runner who now identifies as a woman
it's the same thing we saw with Leah
Thomas it's the same thing we're seeing
happen at Rowan Oak um this was a
mediocre man who is vying to compete
with the women's team and then turns
into this record Smasher destroying all
the women's records it's abysmal and I
think it's nothing short of criminal um
to be totally Frank with you now you
have come out and you've been outspoken
you have really taken a lot of garbage
from a lot of people you get protest
when you show up at at different events
has that part surprised you since you've
just been outspoken on an issue that I
think most Americans frankly agree with
you on you know it does it does surprise
me because I'm saying the most basic
thing men are men women are women there
are two Sexes and you cannot change your
sex I I mean it's it's something we
learn in fifth grade biology yet you
have people with phds professors who are
teaching the total opposite and if you
don't teach the opposite and you are are
adhering to the fact that there are only
male and female you could lose your job
I mean it's crazy the direction this is
going and so the vitriol and the
violence and the hatred that I have been
met with um is surprising but I will be
the first to say that the support that
I've received is tenfold anything
negative there are so many more people
who agree with my stance our stance on
this issue uh then you would be led to
believe if you only watch the news or if
you just saw saw how politicians were
voting I think Americans are a little
bit like me I mean um personally for
adults I'm libertarian I don't really
want to know whatever adults choose to
do in their life is fine I knew Caitlyn
Jenner when Caitlyn was Bruce Jenner and
and we actually had a long very
productive conversation about it and you
know what's interesting is she now says
it doesn't matter what your hormone
levels are when you of college age and
want to play a college sport and you
started swimming you know when you were
four and you're in the pool 6 hours a
day for all these years and you're one
of the top swimmers in the country you
know every all that effort that you put
in it's unfair you know for example she
won't play She's a great golfer she can
drive the ball 275 yards she'll out
drive the hell out of me on most holes
VI if I play it again I haven't played
in a while and my question is and she
just understands there is a difference
why do they feel this compart compulsion
that they've got to indoctrinate kids
force it upon Society if they feel that
that that people are being discriminated
against how about this men's sports
women sports transports start your own
League well we saw this happen uh Fina
which is the international governing
body of swimming after the the whole
Leah Thomas debacle at our national
championships in March of 2022 Fina
created guidelines that said if you've
gone through male puberty you cannot
compete with women and they created a
third category
and at the World Cup in Berlin just last
week this week uh there was not a single
entry in this open category and that
just goes to show I think that's really
proving of what the motivating factor
here is because when we create a third
category no one
competes show if you can't cheat Thomas
you won't compete did not beat you you
tied how come Leah Thomas then was given
first place when it was exact
tie I asked this question right I asked
why why are you adamant on giving the
trophy to Thomas a man in the women's
200 freestyle and the NCAA official
looked at me and Thomas Thomas who's
towering over me at 6'4 and he says his
eyes sunk in okay he visibly his face
visibly saddened and he looked at me
looked at me and said Riley I'm sorry
but we've been advised that when
pictures are being taken it's crucial
that Leah holds the trophy you know you
can pose with this one but again you
have to give yours back back Leah takes
the trophy home end of story they
reduced everything we had worked our
entire lives for as you said since I was
4 years old I dedicated 18 years of my
life to my sport they reduced all of
that down to a photo op to validate the
feelings and the identity of a male at
the expense of our own we became
collateral damag in the process well if
I had an award I'd give it to you
because you kicked frankly Leah Thomas's
ass so um uh and if it's a tie then you
say okay it's a tie that's the truth why
do they Li why do they make special
preference treatment anyway hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else